[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo
de áfrica siete días su magazine 100
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es andrés meza muñoz y en este
capítulo abordaremos las consecuencias
del cambio climático en áfrica a
propósito de la cob 26 las voces
africanas insisten en estar en el centro
de las conversaciones en la cumbre
climática de la cob 26 a pesar de
contribuir menos a las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero el
continente está en la primera línea de
los cambios que amenazan el medio
ambiente en somalia por ejemplo los
desastres naturales han superado el
conflicto como principal factor de
desplazamiento
la cuenca del congo es la segunda selva
tropical más grande del mundo después de
la amazonía los líderes de la república
democrática del congo llegaron a la cob
26 exigiendo todas las medidas
disponibles para preservarla
argumentando que los países ricos
también se benefician de este ecosistema
importante en la lucha contra el cambio
climático tenemos reportes desde glasgow
ruanda está tratando de reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
invirtiendo en formas de transporte más
respetuosas con el medio ambiente la
capital kigali se está transformando en
una ciudad verde con un centro exclusivo
para peatones y bicicletas de uso
público
más de 120 líderes mundiales se
dirigieron a glasgow escocia para la
cumbre climática con 26 ya que los
científicos dicen que la ventana para
actuar se está cerrando rápidamente pero
hoy en día hay quienes ya sufren las
consecuencias y de manera muy marcada
áfrica emite sólo el 4 por ciento de las
emisiones globales pero su gente se
enfrenta a algunas de las peores
consecuencias del cambio climático en
somalia los desastres naturales son
ahora la principal causa de
desplazamiento
[Música]
primero fueron las ovejas y luego las
cabras y cuando murió su último animal
you're up the jam a supo que era hora de
irse como muchos pastores antes que ella
la joven somalí se vio obligada a huir
de su hogar en busca de pastos más
verdes después de que las sequías
consecutivas de smara en su ganado
en el pasado yo siempre dejaba algo para
nosotros pero ahora todos nuestros
animales han sido aniquilados por el
hambre y las enfermedades
tuvimos que huir cuando pierdes todo vas
a donde puedes
anne farc
europe se instaló en este campamento
desolado en las afueras de argés ya una
ciudad poco conocida a cientos de
kilómetros de su pareja natal sin
recursos y pocas habilidades ahora
tienen problemas para alimentar a sus
ocho hijos todos los días su esposo se
dirige a la ciudad en busca de trabajo
pero a menudo llega a casa con las manos
vacías
la familia de europe se encuentra entre
las decenas de miles de migrantes
climáticos en somalia un grupo que ha
crecido en los últimos años a medida que
las sequías y los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos se han vuelto
cada vez más frecuente plan de change y
se ve que el cambio climático es un gran
fenómeno y muchas personas serán
desplazadas a áreas urbanas y el tema de
la migración rural urbana será más tenso
la gente necesitará diversificar sus
medios de vida y fuentes de ingreso
según la acnur alrededor de 3 millones
de somalíes han sido desarraigados de
sus hogares desde 2016 debido al cambio
climático un éxodo con el que el
gobierno somalí que tiene problemas de
liquidez no está listo para limar lo que
a menudo provoca que los migrantes
climáticos queden a su suerte
en la isla de mauricio por ejemplo el
nivel del mar está subiendo tan
rápidamente que el ministerio de medio
ambiente está preocupado de que todas
sus playas desaparezcan en sólo 50 años
para tratar de evitar que las aguas
sigan consumiendo las costas del país
las autoridades intentan reforzar los
malecones
sorprendido por el aumento del nivel del
mar las autoridades de mauricio tomaron
una decisión drástica para construir
muros en su costa
hasta 10 metros de espacios verdes han
sido devorados por el mar y mauricio el
clima no era así antes de invierno y
verano ahora el gobierno es más largo y
el mar mucho más alta
estas importantes obras se iniciaron
hace tres años para proteger 21 áreas
vulnerables aquí en riviéres galets
cientos de familias necesitan una
respuesta urgente según la oficina de
las naciones unidas para la reducción de
riesgos el nivel del mar está aumentando
56 milímetros por año en mauricio casi
el doble del promedio mundial a este
ritmo para el 2100 se espera que el
nivel del mar suba 49 centímetros
este trabajo se ha convertido en una
emergencia para mauricio si no hacemos
nada en 50 años perderemos todas
nuestras playas por eso este trabajo es
necesario ya que el turismo es
fundamental para nuestra economía
en los últimos 70 años la temperatura de
la isla ha subido unos 39 grados el 20
por ciento de la población de mauricio
vive en regiones costeras
veo que el mar sigue acercándose antes
no era así el agua ahora está llegando a
mi terraza escuché que en el futuro las
únicas tres familias que viven aquí
tendrán que desalojar la zona
según científicos locales hasta 80 mil
habitantes podrían verse desplazados en
las próximas décadas hay muchos lugares
en la isla donde la gente se verá
obligada a trasladarse por ejemplo
lidiar de gales por ejemplo tenemos que
vivir de gales y san martãn y estas
personas pueden ser calificadas como
refugiados climáticos en este pueblo se
ha instalado un centro de refugio
equipado con un sistema de alerta para
hacer frente a cualquier peligro
inminente del mar
dentro de las soluciones para mitigar el
cambio climático las voces africanas
apuestan por proteger la cuenca del
congo la segunda selva tropical más
grande del mundo después de la amazonía
los líderes de la república democrática
del congo llegaron a la cob 26 exigiendo
que se tomen todas las medidas posibles
para preservarla y argumentando que los
países ricos también se están
beneficiando de este ecosistema desde
glasgow nuestra enviada especial marina
colorado con los detalles
áfrica es quien más está sufriendo los
impactos del cambio climático a pesar de
ser el que menos ha contribuido al
problema lo hemos visto durante estos
años inundaciones sequías plagas de
insectos que destrozan cosechas y
ciclones tropicales que dejan cientos de
muertos y miles de desplazados que
buscan refugio en otros países y que
causan por consecuencia conflictos
transfronterizos
además el continente tiene al primer
país que está a punto de declarar la
hambruna derivada del cambio climático
france24 habló con la ministra de medio
ambiente de la república del congo que
es la coordinadora de la cuenca del
congo una región que comprende a seis
países africanos y que es la segunda
selva tropical más grande del mundo
después de la amazonía también hablamos
con la vice primer ministro de república
democrática del congo acerca de la
importancia de esta región y de sus
lazos con américa latina
con la que acordamos aquí en la cob 26
que las declaraciones y las
y dan paso a las realizaciones la
república democrática del congo y su
cuenca del congo vienen a dar la
solución a la lucha contra el
calentamiento global con sus macizos
forestales sus redes hidrológicas de
agua dulce y sus minerales estratégicos
para llevar a cabo la transición
ecológica tenemos derecho a acceder a
todos los fondos de mitigación y
adaptación para poder dar esta respuesta
a la humanidad de transmisión de túnez
entre posteriormente el bosón del congo
se te calmo dipus la cuenca del congo
alberga el 10 por ciento de la
biodiversidad mundial así como el
majestuoso río congo el segundo más
grande del mundo después del amazonas
por lo que se entiende que hay que
avanzar hacia esta transición ecológica
pero también hay que crear una economía
alternativa para las comunidades y
poblaciones indígenas con el fin de
preservar estos bienes que forman parte
del patrimonio de la humanidad pero hoy
en día áfrica sólo representa el 0,5 por
ciento de la movilización de la
financiación verdad
efe un curso de movilización de cinismo
vea mientras que más del 90% del
continente africano ha ratificado el
acuerdo de parís ahora le piden a los
líderes de los países industrializados
que más contribuyen al cambio climático
que se pongan más manos a la obra y se
dejen de tantas promesas en la cob 26
algunas soluciones para hacer frente al
cambio climático ya están empezando a
implementarse en algunos países de
áfrica que gali por ejemplo está
tratando de reinventarse como una de las
ciudades más verdes del continente con
un centro de la ciudad amigable para los
peatones días sin automóviles y
bicicletas públicas la capital de ruanda
está invirtiendo cada vez más en la
sostenibilidad
desde que se instalaron carriles para
bicicletas junto a las carreteras
principales de kigali plácido ha usado
este medio de transporte
decidí usar estas bicicletas después de
aprender lo importantes que son y me
ayudan a moverme porque en lugar de
esperar el autobús me toma como 20
minutos llegar a mi lugar de trabajo
a principios de septiembre jura ride
puso a disposición 80 bicicletas para
uso público en la ciudad lo hizo de
forma gratuita durante dos meses el
equipo de espera que a largo plazo las
bicicletas no sean más caras que un
mototaxi
inmediatamente después de descargar la
aplicación inicia sesión con sus
credenciales
luego una página muestra todas las
estaciones de acoplamiento a su
alrededor para un día sin coche una
motocicleta eléctrica el respaldo de
ruanda a una política nacional de
transporte ecológico y asequible es una
estrategia poco común en áfrica
félix en cáncer
como no somos un país productor de
gasolina le cuesta mucho al país y al
final del día el precio del transporte
para cada consumidor es elevado como una
micro movilidad no vamos a usar
combustible entonces son independientes
del combustible lo que en sí mismo nos
da una ventaja para reducir el precio
frente a los otros medios de transporte
la política se introdujo en 2015 para
abordar la congestión en el centro de
kigali el primer carril peatonal acaba
de ser renovado la pista en el ciclable
para los carriles bicicletas ahora hemos
cubierto una red más o menos 17
kilómetros a través de la ciudad
planeamos hacer dos senderos peatonales
más como este en otras partes bastante
pobladas de la ciudad
acevedo live y de ruanda tiene como
objetivo reducir sus emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero en un 38 por
ciento para el 2030
vamos ahora a túnez donde la
contaminación por plástico está causando
estragos el país se ha convertido en un
vertedero donde las bolsas plásticas se
encuentran por todas partes en el suelo
en las playas y en las calles ante la
magnitud del desastre recolectores de
plástico llamados barbés ya trabajan día
y aveces noches para recoger los
desechos y enviarlos a recicladoras
aunque contribuye a la solución del
problema este extenso trabajo dista
mucho de ser suficiente para frenar la
crisis
tienes los residuos de plástico
constituyen un problema considerable
cada año el país norteafricano se
enfrenta a unas 80 y mil toneladas de
desechos lo que pone la fauna los
ecosistemas y la salud pública en
peligro mientras el gobierno se ve
desbordado unos 15.000 recicladores
conocidos como barbecho recorren la
ciudad para recoger el plástico y
enviarlo a las fábricas de reciclaje
criar a laia es uno de ellos les aseguro
que entre el 60 y el 70 por ciento de
los residentes de este barrio trabajan
en la recogida de plástico y en todos
los lugares donde se recogen residuos
como éste se encuentra gente buscando
plástico pese a ello la cantidad de
residuos que obstruye las calles y las
playas de túnez no disminuye
estadísticas estiman que se desechan
diariamente unos 6.8 kilos de plástico
en cada kilómetro de las playas
tunecinas la cantidad de plástico sólo
disminuye un poco en invierno en
comparación con el verano cuando las
botellas de plástico se utilizan en
exceso el gobierno ha tenido problemas
para hacer frente a las situaciones
más de jordi trabaja para una asociación
que compra plástico a los recolectores
afirma que la crisis se refleja a un
estado de deterioro más amplio en el
país las razones son muchas como la
falta de presupuesto la escasez de
camiones para los residuos además de la
escasez de mano de obra las autoridades
afirman seguir trabajando en una
solución
trataremos de encontrar los programas
necesarios para cambiar el
comportamiento del ciudadano y las
disposiciones de eliminación de estas
cantidades de plástico el gobierno
anunció que prohibiera los plásticos de
un solo uso a finales de 2021 hasta que
hasta el capítulo de áfrica siete días
recuerde que se quiere repetir esta u
otra misión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
puntos 24 punto com
[Música]